the full its chapter 2 trailer debut to
light 18 2019 at San Diego comic-con
promising a thrilling conclusion to
director and the music eTI's adaptation
of Stephen King's terrifying novel the
trailer suggests at a vows and
appropriate faithfulness to the flick
source material let's have a look at the
chilling details the trailer opens with
narration from Mike who and like the
rest of the now adult losers stayed in
Derry Maine by the way easier targets
than me and have left then there's a
shot of the sewers where a torrent of
water rolls through a tunnel and snaring
a young victim this scene doesn't seem
to be from the novel it instead looks
like a nod to another film adaptation of
a king classic the 1980 Stanley Kubrick
film The Shining the famous trailer for
that film uses a static shot from the
movie of some unassuming elevator doors
but as a film's title and credits pop on
screen massive volumes of blood gushes
out even as a door stay closed it's
unlikely in the extreme that machete
would have included such a similar shot
by coincidence in King's novel the
number-7 is sort of a mythical totem
that helps to empower the losers to take
on a malevolent being from beyond time
and space but might cozy adult lose us
back to Derry however their chances
against Pennywise are immediately dealt
a blow by the fact that their number is
reduced to 6 Stan URIs the most logical
of the bunch remembers just a bit too
much about that long ago summer upon
receiving Mike's invitation just minutes
after receiving Mike's call Stan commits
suicide it's chapter 2 will clearly
carry over this plot point from the book
in every single one of the trailer shots
are features the entire adult losers
Club Stan isn't there in one of the new
trailers most harrowing sequences James
McAvoy's bill has seen pursuing a young
boy through a carnival funhouse he loses
a youngster in the Hall of Mirrors
finally managing to catch up to him but
they're separated by thick glass in a
horrible echo of his brother George's
faith in the opening of the first film
Pennywise materializes to Menace a child
as a helpless billi frantically kicks at
the glass front houses are meant to be a
little scary sure but those gently
swaying pendulums would make any child
in their right mind run screaming from
the attraction they bear more than a
passing resemblance to penny wise
himself and while some of them are
smiling other sports a look of wide-eyed
object terror
visual signifier that as bill enters the
funhouse he's entering the monsters
domain in a blink in your missing
moments an unidentified man is drove
through the holes of what appears to be
a mental institution oblivious to the
staff member trying to place him into a
chokehold he's fixated with rapturous
joy on a red balloon
Pennywise his calling card floating
outside as fans of the novel the well
aware this is no random patient this is
the adult Henry Bowers who was a child
terrorized the losers Club and fell
under the sway of Pennywise causing him
to kill his abusive father in King's
novel Henry is committed to juniper Hill
Asylum for his crime way he spends
twenty seven years obsessing over his
encounter with forces beyond his
comprehension
when Pennywise returns Bowers escapes
with an assist from the shape-shifting
entity and tries to kill the losers when
the losers reconvene in the book they
decide to split up to individually
explore old haunts of course Pennywise
takes this opportunity to taunt them all
assaulting them with reality warping
experiences that turn the most innocent
of their formative memories on their
heads one of the most memorable of those
sequences involves Richey Tozer
who pays a visit to the town's park with
its hilarycg statue of Paul Bunyan
Richie's solo adventure is briefly
depicted in the trailer as he sees penny
wise gliding along with a bunch of
balloons above that very statue in the
book Henry powers Ganga once chased him
to that exact spot where the Bunyan
statue came to life chasing him down
with his tremendous axe the statue
morphs into a bizarre version of
Pennywise and proceeds to warn him of
his impending doom hi rich what are you
afraid of
count in one sharpener the trailers end
mic is in a crude tent as the world
appears to be shaking itself to pieces
around him he doesn't appear frightened
though he seems almost joyous this may
actually be exactly what's happening in
the shots as he appears to be a
depiction of a ritual that losers
engaged in his children in the novel
this could be a weird kind of flashback
all the filmmakers may have chosen to
move it to the present day it involves a
smoke hole a construct built for a
Native American ritual which Ben
discovers and which is meant to bring
enlightenment sitting in an enclosure
while burning a dry smoky fire the
losers all experience visions one of
which reveals that Pennywise came to
earth from another dimension millennia
ago its impacts similar to that of a
small asteroid created the deep cabins
and the dairy where Pennywise makes its
home the losers are finally able to kill
it for good by engaging in the ritual of
tchard the details of which were
revealed to bill by Mattern a turtle
shaped eternal force of light
diametrically opposed to it
the losers must use their wits knowledge
and love for each other to essentially
Willits into submission in the novel
it's a battle that takes place purely in
the psychic realm where belief and
purity of intention are capable of
defeating even the most malevolent
forces in the trailer the surviving
losers certainly seem to be about to
engage in some sort of ritual
screenwriter Gary Doberman has said that
a form of the ritual of shirred will be
featured in each chapter - describing
his writing of the sequence as trying to
find the most focused accessible way
into some of the more metaphysical
aspects of that book it'll be
interesting to see how he mu sketti
tackled one of the most abstract
climaxes in all of horror literature but
they have our confidence and kings as
well in a tweet the author said simply
looking forward to a chapter - you
should be I've seen it and it's terrific
well no if we agree when the flake hit
screens September 6th check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about it chapter two
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]